ladies and gentlemen Olivia newton-john
good evening and for those of you and
all my family who are watching in
Australia where it's noon tomorrow
g'day as an adopted native of one of the
Majesty's dominions the one far to the
south of Hollywood it's a great pleasure
to introduce two gentlemen who come from
one directly to the north
they are both Canadians both exceptional
actors who have separately appeared in a
staggering array of movies covering all
the bases comedies dramas science
fiction westerns even a Fellini movie
tonight they here together which is only
fitting because they're father and son
please welcome
Kiefer Sutherland and Jonathan
tonight the Board of Governors of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts & Science
is presenting this honorary Oscar to the
National National Film Board of Canada
in recognition of his 50th anniversary
and its dedicated commitment to
originated artistic creative and
technological activity and an excellence
in every area of filmmaking which
resulted in the Film Board distributing
over 6500 productions in English and
French which garnered for them some
3,000 prizes among which were eight
Academy Awards over the years the board
has become famous also for its animated
films the development of 16 millimeter
sound sync handheld cameras and the
world's first 3d IMAX film the film
board is an intrinsic element in the
fabric of Canadian culture and tradition
and it is with great pride that we
introduced to you those who have come
here to accept this reward on the
board's behalf ladies and gentlemen
please welcome the minister of
communications for the government of
canada marcel mauss filmmaker Colin Lowe
and filmmaker and Clair Poitier
thank you very much mercy I'm proud to
accept this Oscar on behalf of the 26
million people of Canada to home the
national fame board belongs the board is
represented here tonight by uncle' of
Poitier and Colin Lowe for 50 years
talented Canadian filmmakers have made
the National Film Board one of the most
respected and honor institutions in the
world say Filmfare not homogeneous
Abbasid or future he'll do Canada in
with some shared only part a govt
clemency again this is a great honor for
the National Board of KM for all
Canadians and we thanked members of the
Academy thank you very much merci
beaucoup
au revoir
the 61st annual capital awards will
return